what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and d23 was today marvel
studios's panel just ended and it was
not what we thought it was going to be
we thought we would get some pretty big
reveals about phase 5 including the cast
of the thunderbolts which we did get
which is really exciting but we also
thought we were going to get phase six
in which unfortunately and very sadly we
did not get which is interesting because
kevin feige said that d23 was going to
be huge and to be fair it actually was
they did reveal a lot it just wasn't
about phase six it was about phase five
but there's a lot of phase five to dive
into a lot of reveals a lot of trailers
a lot of exclusive footage shown at d23
that of course i'll be breaking down
over the next few days and of course
i'll be explaining in this video what we
saw at d23 and breaking down these big
phase five reveals now the first thing
that was shown that i want to talk about
first was new footage for black panther
wakanda forever new footage that they
did not release to the public and that
was a common theme here they showed a
lot of new footage that they only showed
to the people attending at d23 they did
not release this on youtube or anywhere
online but the footage showed a lot of
namor and it showed how strong he
actually is and apparently he is very
very strong they also showed queen
raimondo arguing with people from the
united nations here we see other
countries very frustrated with wakanda
because they now know that vibranium
exists however wakanda refuses to share
it with the rest of the world they
mention the dangerous potential of
vibranium but queen raimonda responds by
saying that she's not worried about the
dangerous potential of vibranium but the
dangerous potential of you meaning the
rest of the world and what they would do
if they got their hands on some
vibranium we then see a very epic fight
scene between the dora melange and a
group of soldiers the group of soldiers
is trying to break in and steal some
vibranium on a ship but the dora milaje
were undercover and they managed to stop
them this pretty much confirms that one
of the main big story plots of wakanda
forever is vibranium and how the world
wants vibranium and possibly even doctor
doom we don't know who the soldiers
belong to they could belong to a
government or they could belong to a
villain we'll have to wait and see on
that one but what they said about the
trailer footage was that this movie
actually looks like it could be better
than the first black panther movie we
then moved on to ironheart and there was
one big reveal here and that is that the
hood is confirmed to be the main villain
of the iron heart series now what we
learned about this project is that it's
going to be about magic and tech so the
two of them colliding so that's probably
going to be pretty interesting to see on
screen it's also confirmed that jim rash
is going to be returning to play his
character from captain america civil war
as the mit guy cracking down on riri
williams's engineering projects of
course we know that she's probably
building an iron heart suit the hood
will deal with dark magic and could
possibly even have agatha harkness
behind him because we do know covent of
chaos is coming relatively soon as well
now the next thing is that we did get a
confirmation for the project werewolf by
knight if you didn't catch the trailer
we'll be talking about it soon but it is
very very old school very frankenstein
vibes and honestly it looks really
really creepy so for those halloween
fans out there and those kind of horror
type fans out there this is going to be
a pretty cool one it is a one-off little
special that they're doing so right now
we are actually kind of unsure if
werewolf by night will be officially
joining the mcu and staying in the mcu
or if this is simply a one-off thing now
check this out this was pretty
disappointing and we'll get on to some
cool stuff like the thunderbolts in just
a bit but they did talk about the
fantastic four for like 10 seconds they
mentioned that mack shackman is indeed
directing the fantastic four and
that was it no casting no nothing
everything that we heard was basically
false it makes you wonder what's going
on with the project they're probably
still trying to get casting done even
though i believe that they were done
with it already but they didn't give us
anything at all besides the director
then we got the official trailer for
secret invasion and it does look like
the scroll truly have infiltrated the
earth we see maria hill talking to nick
fury about how he's been gone for so
long and been unresponsive in
communication but nick fury says that
this is different in that it's a war
that only he can fight we see emilia
clarke's character revealed for the very
first time and we'll be diving into
details about this trailer later on
during the week now we'll get into echo
and daredevil in just a bit because
there were some exciting reveals there
but first let's talk about that
thunderbolts cast marvel studios
officially revealed the entire cast for
the thunderbolts and honestly it's
pretty epic as you can see here they
released concept art of the full
thunderbolts team we have elena bulova
right up front and to her left her dad
not her real dad but the closest thing
that she has to it is red guardian david
arbour who i am super excited is
returning also from black widow all the
way to the right you can see task master
is returning as well and to her left is
u.s agent john walker who we saw be
recruited by valentina allegra de
fontaine in the falcon and the winter
soldier she is also found herself all
the way on the left side of the team and
to her right is ghost who we presumed
was going to be a part of this team and
of course as you see him in the middle
there to the right of elena we have
bucky the winner soldier and it's going
to be interesting to see him fight
alongside with this team especially us
agent john walker if you're unfamiliar
with who the thunderbolts team is it's
essentially a group of not so much
villains even though villains are a big
part of the team but kind of a group of
misfit heroes all of which who have
committed crimes before now they are
working for the government doing
assignments for the government to
essentially stay out of jail it's kind
of their second chance it's basically
the suicide squad and this was probably
the biggest reveal for d23 although
there are some other big ones we're
about to talk about this was probably
the big one now they did talk about
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania they
showed footage for it but it was the
same footage that was shown at sdcc i
did a breakdown of that you can find it
on my channel they did however show a
little bit more of king and apparently
he is absolutely terrifying and jonathan
majors absolutely crushed it with that
role we also saw a little bit more of a
glimpse of kang with the loki season 2
teaser again that was only showed to the
people who were there but what we saw
was loki traveling through different
points in time he was actually being
pulled through different points in time
loki says that he has seen terrible
awful things he also looks at a wall
covered in kang decorations and he says
war is on its way they also did confirm
that ki hoi kwon is going to be joining
the cast and is a tva employee of course
owen wilson was there as well and i'll
do a full breakdown on what we saw on
this loki season 2 trailer later on as
well now for those of you who have been
watching she-hulk and have been talking
about the leader the leader is confirmed
to be returning to the mcu in captain
america new world order returning from
the incredible hulk tim blake nelson is
coming back to the mcu as the leader and
apparently rumor has it so take it with
a big grain of salt because a lot of
rumors were wrong about d23 but
apparently rumor has it that there's
going to be a lot of hulk stuff in
captain america 4 which makes sense
given the connection to the leader the
super soldier serum and of course bruce
banner hopefully this leads up to a solo
hulk film which unfortunately we did not
get an announcement for today now armor
wars got a new logo but that's about it
they did reveal that secret invasion is
going to lead right into armor wars and
roadie seems to be playing a significant
part in secret invasion as well now i
think the second biggest reveal that we
kind of already knew was for ekko and
daredevil they announced the main
villain of the echo series is of course
kingpin they showed footage for ekko and
kingpin was in the very last shot with a
bandage over his eye where ekko shot him
at the end of the hawkeye series as the
cast of the echo series got off the
stage vincent d'onofrio actually stayed
on stage and then charlie cox came out
confirming kingpin is the villain of
daredevil born again as well they then
showed us some she-hulk footage of
she-hulk and daredevil interacting with
each other which we'll see pretty soon
in she-hulk and the last thing that they
talked about and showed us was for the
marvels and they gave a little sneak
peek of that as well just to the people
watching we see nick fury talking to
captain monica rambo as she's wearing an
astronaut suit in space she touches
something in space and swaps spots with
kamala khan in which rambo tells kamala
khan our light-based powers are
entangled which could explain what
happened at the end of miss marvel
captain marvel and kamala khan switched
places and it could be because of this
reason right here and that was marvel's
d23 panel what they did give us was
pretty exciting unfortunately we didn't
really get anything about the fantastic
four nothing about deadpool 3 and
nothing about the mutants which i didn't
really think we'd hear about anyways and
despite these cool reveals and the
really cool trailers and sneak peeks
that we got i know a lot of people
including myself are going to be
disappointed that they didn't reveal
anything about phase six we do have
disney's investors day coming up at the
end of the year but i'm not holding my
breath for that it may be marvel
studios's plan to wait till the next
sdcc of 2023 to reveal the entirety of
phase six hopefully we don't have to
wait that long but as we can see from
d23 there is a lot to keep us occupied
in the meantime a lot of really cool
things happening really soon in the
marvel cinematic universe so if you want
to stay up to date on all the latest
news be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram or twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you